uh well mother's day is around the
corner so what are you getting your mom
don't let her down
well you know it used to be when i was
younger
anything made her happy i could pick
dandelions out of the yard i could bake
her
something i could make her pancakes but
now all she wants
is celebrity male attention what that's
all she cares about because i mean
i took her to meet blake shelton at the
voice one year
and since then since then she gave up
celebrities and she
gave up regular men she can't she all
she wants is celebrities
all she will talk about that's all she
she's uh she's touched justin timberlake
oh she his security tried to stop her
they could not
they could not and right now her big
gift she wants me to find a way to get
lebron james for her so
that's partially i love your mother
right now the three men you just
mentioned
couldn't be more different from the
other no no she says that she gets older
you know she's just open she's like
baskin robbins give me a little spoon of
everything
she wants to try in flavor i love it yup
i'm still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever